stress
raises your blood sugar
i thought this was really fascinating i
remember looking at this you know
looking at my blood sugar like obviously
many times a day when i wore the monitor
and i remember there was a conversation
that was kind of heated and i was a
little amped up
and i look at the data afterwards and my
blood sugar goes up
just from being in a heated conversation
and i just thought that was fascinating
you know it just shows you how
all the systems are at play
this podcast exists because i love
talking to people and i love going deep
the purpose is to plant seeds of
inspiration we enter a space of
vulnerability and relatability and what
you realize is that we are so much more
alike than we are different to quote
ramdas we're all just walking each other
home and this show is just one step i'm
danica patrick and i'm pretty intense
welcome to the pretty intense podcast on
the show today i'm giving you recaps and
lists and everybody loves lists so i've
got a top 10 list of my top 10 things i
learned about health in 2021
i have the six biohacking tips and
tricks that i'm sticking with
uh and then a top five list of general
life
approaches that are the most important
to overall wellness in your life
so
it's a really dense dense dense
information
i think that
hopefully there are some takeaways for
for you um again 2021's been a huge huge
health journey for me um but i feel like
i've also i've also um i've grown a lot
in a lot of different ways so anyway all
those lists if you like what you hear
today and you want to hear more make
sure you click on the subscribe button
2021 has been
very much a health journey for me
2020 i had the year-end like top 20
lessons of 2020
and i felt like i got a a lot of them uh
and it doesn't mean i didn't get lessons
this year but the but the really like
predominant thing that i've been dealing
with this year has been health
um so a quick overview of like what led
it there was that my cycle was delayed
um like december january then i kind of
skipped a couple february march
and now i went to egypt and i and i do
think that might have played an element
you know when you travel abroad and you
um
you know you you shift times of day i
mean i think that can definitely um make
a difference
but i would say that uh i would say that
there was probably just issues going on
so um anyway then i decided i need to go
see my i at that point i'm only new ob
gyn so i was like all right cycle missed
skipped i should see an ob
so i went and i got some tests done to
check my hormones and see if things were
off
and he was like oh your thyroid's off
then he's trying to chase it down with
um i tried a natural
thyroid medicine it made me feel sick
and you know just all kinds of stuff and
he was like you know you should probably
see a functional doctor in the meantime
had interviewed ben greenfield and
he i asked him what what what would i
you know how how could we get how could
i get the information of how should i
eat when should i eat how should i work
out when should i work out all the
details like nitty gritty based on some
data and so he recommended like five or
six tests and um so that kind of all was
happening simultaneously with getting a
functional doctor the functional doctor
came just after he recommended those
things so i ordered all the tests and i
got them and which was great because
it's what she would have ordered anyway
and um so she did add on a couple more
which we end up talking about a lot in
um my health download with ben
but one of them was a provoked heavy
metals test so um we go into detail and
what that is uh but it basically showed
that i had really really really really
high levels of
mercury um
i had other elevated elements to like
lead and thallium and cessium and
something else and anyway so metals were
an issue um but basically it led into
going to going into a gut protocol for
three months because i had leaky gut and
like everything was wrong
um wrong meaning like uh inflammatory of
some sort and then after that was about
getting into a chelation cycle which is
where you get the metals out of the body
again ben and i talk a ton about that in
the episode um
but uh in the middle of it all
i ran a marathon so marathons are really
hard on the body um i mean running in i
mean i think the highest i saw
i think i was doing my 16 or 18 mile run
and i was here in arizona and i didn't
have to do all my long runs in arizona
thankfully but i did do quite a few and
um it was like peaked at like 109
degrees
and it was like i would run from like
sunrise and then just however long it
took so
three hours to do this and um i mean it
was just super damaging on the body it's
just really hard and it's really bad for
you know making leaky gut and gut issues
worse so
um so i ran a marathon so then we
couldn't do the chelation till after
that and so um so that's kind of like
what the phases were but now what i'll
say before i get into some of the
lessons that i've learned this year uh
is that
i remember when all this started the
beginning of the year and hearing about
the thyroid
in probably it was i think it was in
april
and um i was like oh my god that's the
answer i have been suspicious that
something has been off with my hormones
for years
and i remember a few years earlier it
was like just after it was like two
beginning of 2018 i had like changed my
job changed my relationship changed my
living circumstances so much stuff had
changed and i like i had gained a few
pounds and i was like hmm i wonder if
this is just you know age my hair
doesn't seem quite the same like is it
age maybe it's cause i'm not racing
anymore like there was all kinds of
things and i just attributed it to that
it was nothing super dramatic but it was
noticeable to me and being really really
into health and wellness like i paid
really close attention to my body i'm
pretty body aware um
and so then when that came through i
look back and i'm like man it is when i
go through something really emotional so
the beginning of 17 it was like it
always seems to fall some somewhere
between like four and six months after
emotional stuff so
november of 17 like everything changed
end of november and then you know i
started noticing at the beginning of 18
like march time april and then with this
you know i had a you know really bad
breakup in the middle of 2020 and then
like november
time november-ish i remember thinking
man something feels like it's shifted
again like a little bit more weight gain
a little bit like even my face didn't
even look the same there's just so much
stuff that was shifting and and then the
cycle was the thing that really got me
into the doctor because i just i would
gave myself the same attitude that i
would give other people which is just
try harder like maybe you should just do
this maybe
age means you just can't have as eat as
much maybe it means you need to do a
training try a different different kind
of training
and i guess the the kind of the sum of
it all is i would just say if you feel
like something's going on with your body
because i literally thought to myself
maybe something's weird with my hormones
um
and especially if you've had really big
life changes
job living illnesses
breakups all kinds of stuff
anything that's going to be emotionally
taxing
just be aware that it's not just
happening up here it's happening
everywhere
and um so that'll be kind of part of one
of the big lessons from from 2021 with
the health journey but listen to the
body you're really smart you're really
intuitive
um and i think that we're in a phase in
an era of
in culture where we're being asked to to
tap more into that and listen to that
more and more
um so
anyway that's my high level overview of
all the things going on and again ben
greenfield and i went into it but i mean
i i've been getting you know lab draws
and tests just all year i mean basically
from
april through
you know the whole year it's just every
month or even more often and sometimes
there's two months off but it's just
labs and labs and labs and it takes a
long time so i'd say you know be patient
that's what i've learned if i would have
thought to myself in april of 2021 that
you know oh my god this this this one
thyroid pill boom i like joked i'm like
it's my diet pill
because when your thyroid is low it's
basically like the controlling function
of your metabolism and uh and it's just
like if i would have known how much more
was coming on the heels of that i would
have been intimidated but i think it's
like wrapping your head around the idea
that it's going to take time and it
takes time to chase it and that all the
systems overlap so don't get overwhelmed
um just understand that the health
journey is a lifelong one but it's worth
it i'd like to go into the top 10
health lessons
of
2021
so the first one i'm going to start with
lesson number one
rest rest is just not something that i'm
very good at it's not
i'm always thinking to myself try harder
do more
do another workout i mean shoot in my
book pretty intense i write about two
workouts a day and you know i'm just all
about like putting in the effort and at
the end of the day
um
there's so much
so much good that happens internally as
well as externally with the rest i mean
even just from a physicality standpoint
when you work out and tear those muscles
apart like you're kind of in a state of
inflammation never mind what that does
to the insides with adrenals and
cortisol and all that it's it's it can
get dude i think it just really was
detrimental to me to to do so much for
so long
like being someone that
i mean wrote about no rest days like i
don't take rest days um they naturally
happen as and they do it's not like i
don't ever take a day off but i used to
just think they just happen and so you
know my life is a little bit more
structured now i mean i used to
structure it in a way that i'm home a
little bit more so you know i have to
really force myself to take a rest day
but i am learning how how critical they
are and then coming back after rest i
mean my god you really do feel good
lesson number two is walk after you eat
so i used a continuous blood glucose
monitor
this summer for a couple of months
and it was just so informational and
what it's obviously telling you it was
like you'd scan it and you could look at
your current situation on an app
and i would see that after you eat
certain foods of course your blood sugar
rises
and if i would go for a walk it would
blunt it or stop it like it was like it
was almost like a ticking time bomb i'd
look at this thing and i'm like checking
checking checking and all of a sudden
i'm like oh my gosh it's going from 80
to 90 to 100 to 110 120 and you're like
get walking and so you know it's like
you want to see what the food does to
your blood sugar to see if it spikes it
but then it's like a hit at critical
point and as soon as you start moving
around
it totally takes it down so you can kind
of back to back this with foods but
walking after you eat um i mean in the
meadow in the health and wellness they
call like post perennial you know so
it's it's super important um it's really
good for it's just really good to to
blunt that blood sugar response so that
um
it doesn't spike
on the heels of that lesson number three
eat your fat and protein at the
beginning of your meal so this is
another thing that i learned from the
blood glucose monitor is that
the order of the food that you eat is
really important so if you eat your
carbohydrates first it hits your body
first and so
um eating fat and protein but but really
guys it was like a lesson definitely in
like making sure that there's fat in the
meals i could eat a meal that was like
chicken and spinach and
you know chicken and spinach kind of
thing and it would spike my blood sugar
more than other meals and i'm thinking
like it's just chicken and spinach and
that's because you know you're i mean
your blood does it does change with
protein it's like fats the only thing
that doesn't have any effect um but uh
but protein does have somewhat of an
effect and um and carbohydrate
carbohydrate has even more um so i'd say
make sure that you eat fat and protein
at the beginning of all your meals to
help with your blood sugar response with
food
lesson number four
is
fasting windows so lesson number four is
12 hour
rest periods
between
eating windows
i mean i've i've done so much deep
diving into women and fasting windows
and you know there's some that do the
some i do omad which is one meal every
day one one meal one meal every every
day
and then um
and then there's some that do like 18
hour fast some 16 hour fast 14
and really what what the the true like
most beneficial window is 12. and um in
my in my review with ben he definitely
says that for me and especially if
you're a woman
in um
in your reproductive years that fasting
window getting too long can be
detrimental to your to the body and to
your hormones um so 12 hours of rest
between eating windows and then the
benefit of uh of four hours between
meals it actually kind of used to be
something that i would think in my head
because i would eat and then i'd think
man i'm kind of hungry and i'd look and
i'd be like
it's only been two hours though i should
probably hang on a little longer so i
would instinctively always think three
or four hours um
but four hours is the point in which
your bot your stomach has been able to
like turn over the bacteria and so if
you eat on top of that which is snacking
or just having meals too close the gut
bacteria doesn't have a chance to do its
thing and clean out and that can lead to
more bloating
so a little add-on is that yes i mean
the blood glucose monitor helped me
learn to not snack too because if you
have anything to eat you needed to check
it and everything you ate did something
to your blood sugar so
um
12 hour fasting windows um uh between
between your fasting windows and then
four hours between meals
all right lesson number five alcohol
reduces recovery
overnight and i learned this from
wearing a garmin watch and training for
the marathon
and
you know honestly one glass of wine can
disrupt your sleep and of course the
closer you are to to bedtime the worst
because like i would have a if i had a
glass you know before or like early
early early evening um before i ate and
and that doesn't really matter but if
you're eating if you're drinking a glass
of wine after you eat and going to bed
even if it's a couple hours later that
wine definitely has an effect on your
sleep and so what i would see in the
data is i would see and a lot of you
wear wearables i'm sure if you give a
crap about this interview at all it's
because you care about health and
wellness and you probably have a
wearable um
but if you don't or if you isn't
something you pay attention to is
your your hrv your heart rate
variability
or on the garmin it was your body
battery you could see just how elevated
your heart rate was for so many hours
into the beginning of the night and then
finally halfway through the night or so
it drops off and then you finally start
to get recovery
but it really is detrimental so if
you're kind of on the fence about that
glass of wine after dinner just skip it
like it's it really really does reduce
recovery and if there's one thing that i
feel like is probably the most common
like number one thing to do for your
health is to get good sleep so
i make wine but i still would say like
skip that one glass and just save it for
that night do you want to hit the bottle
you know just kidding maybe maybe not
maybe i do both it's just life don't
take it too seriously
um okay number six sweating
so number six is all about the sauna and
learning just about you know i feel like
in the back in the days to hear about
you know sweat the toxins out and i just
kind of used to giggle and laugh like i
don't know if that's just something
people said
um but getting into um
you know the heavy metal detoxification
that i have to do and and um of course
there's a lot to be learned too about i
mean it's really good for cardiovascular
health i think it's uh dr rhonda patrick
talks a lot about the benefits of heat
exposure and infrared saunas
but even when i've wore my garment in
the in the sauna to see what happens
with my heart rate i mean once you start
getting hot
same thing with a bath your heart rate
goes up so there's cardiovascular
benefit to just sitting in the heat
your body has to work a lot but
in the nature of detoxification it does
help the way we get rid of things from
our body is sweating so
sweat
um poop pee all those things anything
that gets out of your body that's
getting rid of toxins so
that can be really helpful and so it's
um
it's something i learned a lot about the
natural way is definitely just to get
out and get moving get sweating go in
the sauna and then if you want to up
regulate that to the next level you'd
incorporate binders
and you would take something like a
charcoal pill or
there's other supplements that include
things like clay and things like that
because when you liberate the metals in
your body you want them to have
something to grab onto so you can get
rid of them as opposed to being
redistributed in the body lesson number
seven
stress
raises your blood sugar
i thought this was really fascinating i
remember looking at this you know
looking at my blood sugar like obviously
many times a day when i wore the monitor
and i remember there was a conversation
that was kind of heated and i was a
little amped up
and i look at the data afterwards and my
blood sugar goes up
just from being in a heated conversation
and i just thought that was fascinating
you know it just shows you how
all the systems are at play you know you
just because you're not running or just
because you didn't eat a just because
you're not lifting weights and doing
something super intense because intense
activity does raise the blood sugar
because your body's going we need to get
this sugar readily available so that we
can use it for the workout um and it's
not from eating a sweet potato or banana
or oatmeal or something like that that
spikes my that's spiking the blood sugar
this is purely just my emotions
so
i think that's why you know it points in
the direction so much of meditation and
and mindfulness practices and whatever
you can do to
to stay calm so
uh so yeah that's a bad news stress
makes your blood sugar level go up
lesson number eight
walking lowers the blood sugar okay
walking does a whole bunch of things but
walking is like the most walking i think
is underrated it's a powerhouse tool
you can do it as much as you want you
can walk
as much as you want it's a low impact
low exertion thing and what i found
fascinating was that it would actually
lower my blood sugar level where you
know super intense physical activity
spikes it this was actually lowering it
even if food wasn't even at play it
lowers the blood sugar so walking is
really good for that it's good you can
do it all the time you're getting
vitamin d which is so essential i mean i
feel like in the last couple years i
feel like vitamin d is something that
we've been hearing so much about is how
beneficial that is for um
overall health um and you're out in
nature like there's just you can
there's there's very little that can go
wrong with walking it's a really really
really great thing and plus i use it as
an extra benefit i always take the dogs
with me they need the activity too so
get out there get the sunshine get it
directly onto you get it onto your skin
absorb some vitamin d and um and do as
much of it as you want
lesson number nine
is the benefits of red light
so
red light i got the juve red light and
um as i learn more about it i'm happy to
try things even if i don't necessarily
always know exactly what it does
but as i get it and then i learn more
about it it helps to repair and
strengthen the mitochondria which is
the powerhouse of every cell of your
body and it gives you energy it's like
with the energy forces within every cell
so the red light and it's mimicking an
aspect of the sun so
that's why the recommendation that ben
gave me was to do it at the beginning of
the day and the end of the day sunrise
sunset to mimic
the sun it's a great time for your body
to absorb that frequency
so red light is really good for the
mitochondria and then on the contrary as
a little add-on blue light so i got some
blue light blocking glasses uh and
they're cute they're not they don't all
have to be ugly um i think
felix gray or something like that was
the company i got him for from i ordered
him off of goop i mean what doesn't goop
have
uh and so blue light helps to the reason
why you want to wear it at night is
because it's r it's it's killing those
the the blue light frequency um but the
other side of it is that it wakes you up
so
you know it's not it's not that blue
light is always bad it's just that if
you want to reduce any of it it's better
to do it at night because you want to
activate your melatonin you want things
to start shutting down and you don't
want that stimulating frequency to to
hit get into your eye and affect your
hormones so
blue light and it also disrupts the
mitochondria a little bit so but i let's
just stick with blue light wakes you up
and um reducing it will help you sleep
better at night which is why they always
recommend you you know the most the best
time to wear your glasses is at night so
i started to do that and lesson number
10
our whole body it's just there's just
one system
the body is one system
and
everything matters i used to look at the
body as being like i had my um i had my
emotional bucket i have my energy bucket
um i have my mental bucket like i have
all these different energy systems
working and i could tap any of them at
any time it was just that i didn't want
to double down on them like you know if
you've got a lot of mental things going
on okay like i can't handle another
thinking activity right or if i worked
my upper body
yesterday i even thought my body had
different systems i was like well i i
mean my upper body's sore but my lower
body's not sore so i can go kill that
now um and and and then and then there's
the emotions you know there's being
tapped from doing things that are
emotional i think we can all probably
understand and associate what that's all
about whenever we get emotionally
drained i mean we can feel that in our
whole body
but
um it's just kind of a reminder that the
everything is working together and in
unison and it matters the biggest thing
i've learned with like the functional
medicine route is that not only from the
uptake forms that you have to do before
they're asking things like i mean the
questions are like
what do you remember what how was your
childbirth you know things like that
they want to know what kind of
imprinting's happening from the very
beginning so everything matters and i
suppose you know in if i'm going to sum
up probably the the sum of my
my health journey so far this year is
that initially it seems like oh my
cycle's off and it's like oh maybe it's
a thyroid and now i'm like okay i
actually think maybe now after all this
testing it might actually be the heavy
metal toxins because
the heavy metals are reducing my gut
health and uh liver function and t4 is
can converted into t3 and t3 is the
available energy that we use from the
thyroid
in the liver and in the gut so if those
things aren't working it doesn't convert
it's not that i was low on t4 i'm low on
t3 the available
the available aspect of the thyroid um
that produces energy and so um
anyway the point is is that it's very
complicated everything is working in
unison and i think it really goes back
to lesson number one which is rest like
by default rest and i don't mean be a
glutton it doesn't mean and sit around
and eat pizza and whatever else but like
you can walk as much as you want so
walking sunlight
nourishing your body with really healthy
things i encourage people to take some
tests like take a blood panel figure out
what's going on um
if you're gonna pay for your health
sooner or later and um you know part of
the part of the advice from ben just had
a lot to do with you know looking after
your health as it goes and doing things
weekly monthly quarterly yearly instead
of getting to the point where it's all
summed up into one and that's kind of
where i ended up because it all got
summed up into one and
i
now will be on a much more frequent
protocol with a lot of different things
so they don't ever have to be in this
position again um but to sum it up yeah
the body it's just one motherboard
system and that by default rest is a
really smart thing if you even think
you're overdoing it
you probably are now i'd like to share
uh the top six
i would call them more biohacking
uh modalities that i really believe in
and that i've tested and that i've used
or i've done and i think they're really
beneficial um so number one i i totally
believe in the juve red light or
whatever red light you want i really
believe in that um i think it actually
i don't know call me crazy i feel like
it almost changes the texture of my skin
and makes it smoother
but it's helping your mitochondrial
function and mitochondria is the the
powerhouse of the cell that creates
energy so anything that we can do to
help with the mitochondria is a good
idea so red light i'm sticking with it
um
number two
is infrared sauna
there's lots of lots of uh good data out
there about all of the more nitty gritty
details and what the infrared sauna does
but in general it's really good for
cardiovascular cardiovascular health and
it's also really good for detoxing and i
think in this sort of day and age that
we live in it's almost impossible to
avoid um toxins like we're walking
outside to our car we're getting on an
airplane you name it it's there's toxins
and so to conjoin the sauna with also a
little bit of binder too i think is a
great great practice charcoal clay
something like that to uh to bind the
bind it bind to
so that the heavy metals get excreted
number three magnesium you know
magnesium is just one of those things
it's kind of hard to get enough of
even in all of my blood tests and
testing magnesium is something that has
been low in me even with supplementation
so i would say that probably magnesium
is another really
really great added
supplement that
it's hard to get enough of
that really helps you with to feel
better energy function
they're helpful for detoxification
pathways too so magnesium great one
number four
vitamin d plus k2 vitamin d is something
especially i think that if they say if
you're north of
i don't even know might be like atlanta
georgia or something it's pretty far
south but if you're north anywhere of
that that for a for a
general portion of the year when it's
obviously cold and and snowy in some
spots you're just not going to be able
to get vitamin d you're going to have to
supplement it so there's some places you
can get enough vitamin d but even for me
living in arizona i still didn't get
enough vitamin d and i mean i go outside
i don't even wear sunscreen so like even
if there was an idea that sunscreen is
blocking vitamin d absorption i don't
really wear any so um
so i think a vitamin d supplement is an
excellent thing to add on to your
regular protocol
number five uh the quality of your water
so i'm talking about everything from the
way from what it comes in to what you
put in it so um i currently have a
little protocol with um my oh my god my
giant giant jug my gallon jug of water
um where i add in um minerals
uh i add in um sometimes i put
electrolytes in there too
so i just like stack my water i use a
reverse osmosis system um to really
clean the water but of course when you
clean it just like if you clean the body
you redo you get rid of other things too
so
you're reducing the mineral content by
nature with reverse osmosis so minerals
electrolytes um but really looking at
the the
the water itself and then the the
container it's in i
i can't tell you how worried i was how
many friggin bottles of plastic bottles
of water i drank in my career like i
just got handled another water bottle
and then another water bottle and
another water bottle and that's what i
drank in my bust when i'd be traveling
and i try and do a better job of
refilling water bottles not defaulting
to getting a bottle of water out
somewhere i don't care if it's your
essentia or whatever evian like it's
still in a plastic bottle so as much as
you can do to get your water into into
glass and into water bottles reducing
plastics i think is a great idea so
quality of the water is important
thera-body boots okay so when i trained
for the marathon
um
my friend got these thera-body boots we
went to the crossfit games and she loved
them and i thought okay fine and they
just pressurize from your foot from your
toes all the way up to the top of your
leg and they release and they just keep
cycling it
and um to sort of flush your legs out
and and get them to um not feel so sore
and so i didn't really believe in the
boots until
her and i ran it was the last run we did
in chicago and it was i think we did
like 16 miles or something like that it
was kind of like the last long run we
had already done 20 so it was like a
little bit less maybe we even ran 14.
it was kind of a warm day get back we
slip into the boots and i mean my legs
are pretty sore and running the 16 and
the 18 and the 20 like my legs could be
were pretty sore um but i put them in
after that and i went from not really
being able to walk very well
to
walking
just fine and i was like okay wow
these things work so especially like
right after a hard workout especially
obviously if it's lower body
it's insanely beneficial i'm talking
about if you're doing your biking
running
weight lifting you name it anything with
the lower body that's taxing put these
boots on afterwards for i mean i put it
of course at like 30 minutes max
pressure um but anyway it works so
thorough body boots are awesome so those
are my top six the red light infrared
sauna magnesium vitamin d
quality water
and fair body boots
i've covered you know my top 10 like
health lessons of the year
i covered the more
bio hacking top tips and things that i'm
going to stick with that i like
and then of course a long long
explanation into the depths of more of
my labs and all the things i have going
on with ben greenfield um
i think it's i think it's a good idea to
just recap just in totality so here are
the top five
best
life practices
number one
eat real food
i mean it it's just simple just eat real
food don't try and supplement shortcut
but eat real food and eat mostly paleo i
mean paleo is a great diet because it's
mostly a whole foods diet so you know
all else fails i even think to myself if
like if i have time if i'm running out
and i have to grab something it's like
should i eat a half of an avocado or
should i just grab a bar and you're like
just take the two seconds and just eat
the avocado like eat the real food even
if like you're thinking well there's no
protein in that it's like they still the
body recognizes real food so eat real
food and paleo is a great place to start
if you're not sure what diet's best for
you number two
movement
just move like honestly just throughout
the day as i said walking you can do as
much of that as you want but also like
just getting up in the middle of the day
and just taking a walk i think people
probably wear wearables i think they
tell you to get up they give you you
know step counts and stuff that's all
great
um but anything to just kind of get up
regularly throughout the day and just
move around
you know one of the additional things i
learned
i had talked about in my in my lessons
that walking will reduce your blood
sugar spike after eating but what i
found too is that not only just walking
but getting up so if i got up and i did
dishes i cleaned the house i did laundry
whatever it is if you just get up
and move around it also does a pretty
damn good job so just general movement
general movement and walking is um by
default the best thing that you can do
every day get some movement go for a
walk get in nature get some sunshine
number three most important thing is
sleep i add sleep because i know it's
important um and i definitely was able
to see with my with my garmin wearable
like what it looked like with
um not recovering in sleep and even my
friends who did the marathon with me and
wore their watches they could see if
they were getting sick i mean it was
starting to indicate things like that so
um
i think that you know sleep is obviously
something to talk about i'm only just
sort of saying all this because i'm a
pretty good sleeper um which i feel
really fortunate about but
but that's like the number one thing in
life is just if you if you if you're not
getting enough sleep you should really
figure out how to try and get more and
then if you're not able to sleep you
should obviously be trying to figure out
how to get better and you know i do
think that there's an emotional element
to it i mean that's just my two cents
but there's a lot of stuff that goes on
in people's heads and you do a lot of
thinking if it requires putting a
notepad next to your bed so you can
write things down fine but it also can
get into them deeper levels where you
know there's just things going on in
life and things that you're really
questioning and worried about and you
know all of that worry will will will
make sleep tougher you know maybe you
can't stay asleep i've definitely had
those waves where you know
i can fall asleep pretty easy but you
know i don't stay asleep and i'm waking
up and i'm getting five hours of sleep
and i wake up at 5 a.m or 6 a.m cause i
went to bed at one and i'm like i'm up
and you know i probably should be able
to sleep more than that so it's it's
happened but i i generally am a pretty
decent sleeper but i also think probably
if i have a top tip for sleeping
is um outside of the emotional stuff is
um
make it cold
make your room cold i tell you what i
have slept if the room is i try and
target 66 to 68
um if the room it should feel a little
bit cold when you go to bed but if the
room is 70 71 i mean i'll know it i
won't be able to sleep but if the room
is like 58
i'll just sleep like a like a bear like
it is not a problem if it's on the cold
side versus the hot side but if it's on
the hot side it's much harder so there's
a lot of evidence around this but
definitely getting the room cool enough
i think is like the top first tip i'd
give anyone
um number four
is stress management
so this is where like just mindful
modalities come into it and so i mean
there's somebody that's gonna be like
learn how to meditate they're gonna be
like someone that's gonna say something
else someone's gonna say
do your cold shower do your do your
sauna do your whatever do your gratitude
practice make your five you know things
that you want to accomplish that day and
what you're grateful for there's a
million different things that you can do
and the truth is is that you just need
to figure out which one works for you
so um some people it's meditation some
people to walk some people it's gonna be
um you know a gratitude practice
sometimes it's prayer
um whatever it is you just gotta figure
out what works for you and sometimes
it's breathing i mean i had wim hof on
he was telling you talk about all the
benefits of you know breathing and
breathing is a super powerful tool i
mean you can pretty much get yourself
high with breathing so um so that's
another tool so it's really just about
what do you do to decompress what is
your stress management tool
um
you know for me it's like a couple deep
breaths really helps and just a walk
like for me a stress management tool
that's the best is just taking a walk
um so and probably because of what i've
mentioned already which is that lowers
blood sugar it's probably lowering
cortisol and it's relieving the adrenals
from all the work that it has to do so
um i do think that that finding your
stress management tool is critical and
it could it might take some time but
it's useful for life then
and number five is in general life is
about perception and i'm sorry but
that's all on you aka all on me
my life is my fault your life is your
fault it just is it's your it's your pa
it's the power of perception and i know
that like shitty things happen
but also haven't we met those people
that have shitty things happening in
their life and they're like you know
what i'm really grateful it's given me a
deeper connection with this person or
i've learned so much or i have things in
perspective now there's always a way to
flip it and
it's okay to feel it for a minute i
don't think it's all it's not about
spiritual bypassing or
acting like everything's okay and
pushing things down it's about looking
at what's really happening
and then going
give yourself a window i don't know
maybe it's i mean i think i was
listening to tony robbins say he gives
himself like 90 seconds to worry about
something i give myself a day or two so
you know i'm not tony robbins yet but
you know give yourself a certain amount
of time in which you're gonna allow
yourself to
um be in a space
um and then and then snap out of it and
understand that your life is all about
your perception and that will trickle
into everything else that happens in
your life because your perception
becomes your energy your energy carries
a frequency and your frequency is
attracting your real world to you so if
you've got a lot of problems you're
going to keep finding a lot of problems
if you if you feel amazing and you're
really like loving and hopeful and
optimistic you're probably going to get
a lot more of that and a lot more people
of that same mindset so
eat real food
move all day every day
get good sleep
figure out your stress management tool
and
never underestimate the power of
perception on your life
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today i hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the subscribe button